ladies and gentlemen Caucasian in
melanin my name is Utkarsh Ambedkar I
did the halfway point recap of the show
it went so well that they're asking me
to do it again I'm reading this for the
first time one take here we go okay me I
thought 1917 was mean but turned out
parasite tonight cleaned up
yeah joaquin he quoted his brother river
and one of the best speeches I've ever
seen delivered Zellweger one for the of
the movie and she spoke through invoking
Judy Brad Pitt as I said previously
should have won an award for playing
World War Z Laura Dern she added a brand
new chapter she got an Oscar and fought
velociraptors and don't you know pong
joon-ho you won for director it's good
bro that you didn't get drunk in the
middle of the show tourists oh everyone
loved to Woody and Buzz and I'd like to
say my daughter loves hair love Jojo
rabbit one tyke a kind of a stunner you
could see us both in free guy this
summer original screenplay again to
parasite pong Juno I don't know how it
is that you write that things you do
back to 1917 that was the dopest
cinematography I've ever seen American
factory Congrats to Barak learning to
skateboard shoutout to Tony Hawk alright
here we go
rocking don't you know that one for Best
lab was neighbors window what you like
best international film was won by
parasite parasite parasite what three
four times but anyway I'm here spitting
an Oscar ROM board first Ferrari film
editing kept the BP beeping it's the
only movie that I saw with my dad that
he didn't fall sleeping sound editing
also 1 by 4 verse Ferrari
vroom-vroom-vroom-vroom you won two
awards in the room broom group sound
mixing went to 1917 oh my gosh Sam
Mendes your movie was so me production
designed Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
but shout out to Bollywood
anyway Original Score went to Joker oh
man Hildur that was beautiful I hope
your whole career goes so so well I
loved everything you do with it man was
there original song went to Elton John
oh my gosh listen all the y'all tonight
I followed Eminem and opened up for
Elton John oh my god your boy had it
goin on makeup yeah they did it so well
they made Charlize look more beautiful
in bombshell costume designed the little
women now I'm here spitting the free
rhythm okay visual effects were done
it went in 1917 my son my name's utk and
I came to say
that's Oscars 2020 hope you have a nice
day